-Welcome, welcome welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
I appreciate that.
Guys, this Sunday is Easter.
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
And I saw that on Monday,
the Bidens will host the annual
White House Easter Egg Roll.
Yeah, on Monday.
[ Laughter ]
It's like someone saying
come to my epic
New Year's Eve party
on January 2nd.
[ Laughter ]
It'll be weird when
the Easter Bunny hugs Biden,
and underneath the mask,
you hear,
[as Donald Trump] "You have to
pardon me, please."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I heard that
this year the White House
is debuting a new bunny mascot.
Yeah, it's a little different
than the bunnies
the last president hung out
with, and...
[ Laughter ]
The White House Easter Egg Roll
is always a fun event,
but I hope it goes better
for Biden than it did last year.
Oh, man.
-He's off.
Pull your feet in!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Oh!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
Is he alright?
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
[ Laughs ]
That's the best --
that's is the best video
I've ever seen in my lifetime.
[ Screams ] He always
gets hit by...
It's unbelievable.
Falls in a river.
Oh, my God.
-Speaking of Easter,
since eggs are so expensive
right now, this is real,
a group called Potatoes USA
said that Americans
should paint potatoes instead.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Painting potatoes
instead of eggs.
I know that's not true,
but in my head
it's what Easter
is like in Russia.
[ Laughter ]
Even your grandpa, who lived
through the Depression was like,
That's bleak.
On the bright side,
Mrs. Potato Head
is like makeover.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
Sweetgreen has renamed their
Chipotle chicken burrito bowl
after they were sued by Chipotle
for trademark infringement.
Yup, Sweetgreen said that they
won't make that mistake again
and introduced
their new
Sweetgreen cheesy
gordita crunch.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, baseball is back.
And here in New York, fans are
excited about the Yankees.
21-year-old rookie
shortstop Anthony Volpe.
Is it or is it -- is it Volpe
or is it -- or is it "Volpa"?
I always --
I heard it both ways.
-Oh, come on. If you're going to
talk about the players,
you've got to know
how to pronounce their names.
-Oh, so you know how to
pronounce every
Major League Baseball
player's name?
-[ Scoffs ]
Yeah, I'm an announcer.
It's kind of my job, you know?
So go ahead, test me
with some names.
-I'll give you a names.
Real quick.
Who's this?
-Oh. Jerry Springer.
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Who's this?
-Zac Efron.
You've got to give me
some hard ones, man.
Rapid fire me.
-You want rapid fire?
Alright, here we go.
Who's this?
-That's Eva Longoria.
Jurassic Park.
Oh, Yummy Cheerios.
Finding Nemo.
Wendy's in Panera.
I see a killer Falafel.
[ Laughter ]
All about that bass.
Oh, Boba Fett.
That guy right there.
Nick at Nite.
Colin Poke.
Loose Urine.
Juicy Fart.
Areola.
Great Crotch.
My Willy's Castrated.
Masturbates.
No, no, no, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, okay, okay, okay.
Last one.
I'll give you his name
and you tell me if it's correct.
Okay?
-Okay, great.
-Pierce Johnson.
-Well, I just call him
by his nickname, Ouch.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Steve Higgins,
everybody right there.
Steve Higgins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, guys, I saw that there's
a new documentary
on Hulu
called "The Pope Answers,"
which features young people
asking the Pope questions.
Yeah, I guess the pope
is trying to connect
with the younger people,
but I don't know.
I think he's trying
a little too hard.
Take a look at this clip I saw.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ice --
Ice cream
and Fruit Roll-Ups?
This is going viral, guys.
This is real.
This is funny.
Someone ordered
a cake from Costco
and they gave them
a design to work from,
but I think they took it
too literally.
Here's the design, right?
Alright,
and here's what they got.
[ Laughter ]
It's weird,
they completely messed up,
but they also did a great job?
Costco immediately apologized
and redid the cake.
Here's the cake now.
There you go.
That's perfect.
[ Applause ]
You guys, there's a lot going on
in the news right now,
but instead of me
just telling you about it,
I thought it'd be nice
to give you the chance
to decide what we talk about.
That's right, it's time for
You Pick The Joke. Here we go.
-♪ You pick the joke ♪
♪ Ha, ha, ha ♪
♪ You pick the joke ♪
-So, here's how it works.
I'm going to show you
two news stories,
then you guys get to pick
which one we talk about, okay?
Alright, here we go. Let's take
a look at story number one.
-Finland is officially
joining NATO
as the military alliance's
31st member.
-Okay.
Here's story number two.
-A bizarre story
out of Northwest Oklahoma City.
A woman was trying
to break into a home.
She gets stuck in a chimney,
and it turns out she was
not wearing any clothing.
-Alright.
-Which story do you want
to talk about? One or two.
[ Audience shouts ]
Good choice.
That's a good choice.
That's right, a woman got stuck
in a chimney naked.
It sounds like Mary Poppins
got an OnlyFans.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's do another pair
of stories once again.
You guys get to pick.
Here's story number one.
The U.S. housing market
split in two.
Prices are falling on one side
of the country,
still holding in there
on the other.
-Okay.
And here's story number two.
-Police say that a man
went to extremes
to avoid capture after breaking
into a home in Florida.
They actually found him
in the attic,
buried in the insulation
with his face
against the air duct system
to breathe fresh air.
[ Laughter ]
Which one are you talking about?
One or two.
-Two.
-That's right
a burglar tried to hide himself
by burying himself
under insulation.
This is also what it looks like
when you go skiing
with Gwyneth Paltrow.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's do one final round.
Here's story number one.
-Gas prices could soon
be headed higher
after OPEC plus countries
announced
a major cutback
in oil production.
-And here's story number two.
-In Brevard County,
a ride to a job interview
ends with some charges.
A man was arrested
after allegedly
going 100 miles per hour
in a 40-mile per hour zone.
He told police he had
to get his girlfriend
to a job interview
at a Taco Bell.
-Alright, which one?
Want to talk about one
or you want to talk about two?
-Two.
-Two? Great choice.
Usually if you hear
100 miles per hour in Taco Bell,
it's someone running
to the bathroom.
There, you guys.
That's You Pick The Joke.
-♪ You pick the joke ♪
♪ Ha, ha, ha ♪
♪ You pick the joke ♪
-And finally, as I mentioned,
the White House Easter egg roll
is on Monday.
And the thing I look forward
to every year
is seeing the White House
Easter Bunny,
because every year
the bunny looks different.
Here,
I'll show you what I mean.
♪♪
♪ Bunny in a vest ♪
♪ Bunny in a dress ♪
♪ Bunny on a porch ♪
♪ Bunny hugging George ♪
♪ Bunny with Biden ♪
♪ Bunny looks frightened ♪
♪ Bunny is Spicer ♪
♪ Bunny took Pfizer ♪
♪ Bunny looking basic ♪
♪ Bunny needs Lasik ♪
♪ Bunny wants kisses ♪
♪ Bunny is complicit ♪
♪ If Bunny tells all ♪
♪ Then Donnie might fall ♪
♪ So give hush money ♪
♪ To the White House Bunny ♪
We have a great show.
The Jonas Brothers
are here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chloe Bailey
is joining us,
and we've great magic with the
Foodie Magician here tonight.
Stick around, we'll be right
back with thank you notes.